[Musique]
la distanciation social rendre à la
reprise des activités de l'industrie
culturelle extrêmement complexe avec
nous ce soir lorraine pintal directrice
générale et directrice artistique du
théâtre du nouveau monde de bonsoir
lorraine pintal
bonsoir monsieur clients commencent à
voix basse moi ça va mais vous comment
ça se passe comment allez vous et
comment va le tnm en ce moment on doit
et c'est une question un peu cliché dans
les circonstances parce qu'on sait bien
qu'on vit une situation de crise
exceptionnelle du jamais vu
le théâtre du nouveau monde ont vécu la
même situation que beaucoup de salles de
spectacles avec l'obligation de
fermeture
naturellement pour la santé du public
des artistes de nos employés c'était la
décision à prendre mais on nous dit on
il est quand même le tiers de notre
programmation et ça pour ce qui est
d'une direction artistique ce qui est le
plus dur à vivre le deuil à faire bien
sûr c'est de mettre à pied des artistes
qui avaient des contrats avec nous et
qui se retrouve dans une situation
encore plus précaire que celle qu'ils
vivent normalement et nous employer on
compte sur le programme du 75% du
fédéral pour les ramener au travail de
plus rapidement possible et bien sûr que
vous allez utiliser la subvention
salariale du gouvernement fédéral
oui on est admissible alors ça va nous
permettre de rapatrier tout notre monde
et vous savez l'expective de ces gens là
elle est exceptionnelle alors on peut
pas se permettre de perdre
cependant là et on est en pleine relance
en plein planification de relance parce
que on croit ou des consignes mans
progressif et on garde encore un regard
optimiste sur la situation à 5 e
peut-être que nos salaires et ouvriront
à l'automne mais n'en oublie mais en
même temps quand on entend le premier
ministre le veau le premier ministre
hugo puis tous les scénarios de
réouverture on n'a pas l'impression que
les salles de spectacles ce seront les
premières activités qui vont reprendre
loin de là parce qu'il ya déjà beaucoup
de rassemblement est ce que ça vous
inquiète sûr c'est très inquiétant c'est
comme une épée de damoclès qu'on est au
dessus de la tête mais comme l'ensemble
de la population
on veut tous savoir quelle est la date
on va pouvoir commencer à faire du
déconfinement progressif
alors nous on de différents scénarios
bien sûr ces facteurs de relance ils
dépendent des décisions gouvernementales
et des appuis des gouvernements ils
dépendent aussi des artistes du public
qui sont là ce bail pour recommencer nos
activités et aussi du milieu des
affaires qui on le sait très mobilisés
pour permettre justement ce lien entre
l'art la culture et la communauté
alors on fait de multiples scénarios il
ya un scénario noir qui veut que on en a
pour un an le scénario pessimiste qui
fait qu'on on ne lèvera pas en fait nos
spectacles pour le début de la saison et
un scénario où on pourrait et c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire trouver des
moyens de maintenir ce lien vivant entre
l'artiste et le public c'est le sens
fondamental de notre existence par des
mesures sanitaires extrême par une autre
manière d'accueillir le public part
peut-être accepter qu'il y ait moins de
revenus de billetterie et qu'on joue les
spectacles peu plus intime
on retrouvait des solutions qui vont
nous permettre de rester vivant auprès
est à la fois des artistes et du public
mais vous aussi vous souhaitez me
reprendre en septembre vos spectacles
apprend bien coûter c'est ce qu'on
souhaite tous reprendre en septembre
mais on fait partie de la même société
que tout le monde et on voit bien que
c'est peut-être pas pour demain cette
reprise là ils savent où là mais nous
savons le même prix pour rallye sport
pour tous les grands lieux de
rassemblement nous serons tous touchés
par cette mesure de fermeture de nos
lieux de spectacle à l'intérieur pour
l'économie montréal c'est important sur
le plan économique que l'industrie en
guimaëc culturel de montréal
c'est très important il faut savoir que
le poids économique que d'une salle de
spectacle et donc de plusieurs salles de
spectacles et de l'industrie du
spectacle
c'est extrêmement important pour la
viabilité économique
est ce que j'aime bien en ce moment
c'est que les gouvernements semblent
comprendre que nous faisons partie d'un
maillot
enchaîne culturels sociaux économiques
politiques et que l'artiste est un
véritable acteur de cette relance
économique et on a besoin de leur appui
on a besoin d'entendre de la part de nos
politiciens que l'art et la culture sont
un service essentiel est que nous
pouvons nous aussi contribué à cette
valence et vous cette fête dans ce
cas-là du 500 millions qui étaient
octroyés à peu pris moins de canadiens
pour soutenir la culture et des artistes
moi je suis très satisfaite j'ai hâte de
voir les modalités on a un rendez vous
bientôt avec le ministre du patrimoine
steven guilbeault parce que il ya des
consultations par visioconférence alors
ona de connaître les modalités et je
trouve que l'autre mesure qui a été très
apprécié pour les travailleurs autonomes
c'est ce que j'appelle le filet social
donc la prestation canadienne d'urgence
ça permet quand même des travailleurs de
voir un peu des fins de mois sans trou
dans gouin et pour moi c'est une mesure
qui devrait être durable il ya peut-être
des choses qui vont rester de cette
crise là et qui vont nettement améliorer
la condition des artistes dans notre
société alors oui et des mesures on
attend le camp de relance du ministère
de la culture du québec qui je l'espère
va compenser aussi financièrement
l'absence de revenus parce que vous
savez le public est un acteur aussi très
généreux très solidaire le billet
solidaire beaucoup de gens y ont adhéré
plutôt que de demander aux
remboursements de billets pour les
spectacles reportés
il accepte de faire un don de leurs
billets maintenant ce qui m'inquiète
bien sûr c'est la pauvreté qui vont
suivre la crise les gens vont pas
nécessairement les moyens de nous
fréquenter assidûment
alors c'est là on va faire preuve
d'imagination encore une fois et de
créativité et c'est le propre de l'art
et et de voir comment on peut maintenir
vivant cet art qui est l'art vivant
théâtre de la danse de la cause et on
connaît votre énergie lorraine pintal
votre optimisme également ça s'entend
bien
vous avez la conviction donc que vous
allez passer à travers cela on va passer
au travers des facteurs qui nous aide à
passer au travers
j'ai parlé des gouvernements j'ai parlé
du milieu des affaires et aussi bien sûr
les artistes et le public ce sont trois
facteurs
sans lesquels une institution théâtrale
ne peut exercer son véritable rôle parce
que nous avons un rôle aussi de cohésion
sociale c'est très important l'an nous
on garde un oeil très attentif sur
d'autres domaines le domaine de
l'éducation
on suit de très près le tourisme parce
qu'on parle aussi de l'internationalisme
donc de cette position qu'occupe le
québec sur la scène internationale
l'environnement le milieu des affaires
et bien sûr tout ce qui nous permettrait
de trouver un certain équilibre à
travers les réseaux sociaux le numérique
bien sûr mais il faut savoir que le
numérique n'est pas sans faille
c'est formidable des réseaux sociaux y
sont vraiment des véhicules de la
créativité de l'artiste en ce moment
mais c'est quand même une c'est pas la
panacée voilà ça restera un art vivant
ce qu'on fait quand je n'ai vraiment du
théâtre et ce qui est fondamental pour
nous c'est de maintenir justement ce
lien entre le théâtre l'artiste peut
alors mais c'est bien sûr que les
mesures de distanciation social de
faudra ménage avec le théâtre une chance
bon courage je vous arrête maintenant
c'est terminé pour voir le médecin